I'll just start with a simple page that
has three divs contained within
container div in normal block layout
each div is positioned one underneath
the other one but once I add display
flex to the container div the divs are
now shown in a row that's because the
default flex Direction is row by default
flex items fit on a single line so no
matter what I set the width of the
elements to be they won't wrap instead
the browser will size them to fit within
the viewport I can change that by adding
flex wrap wrap to the container element
that tells the browser that it's okay
for the elements inside to wrap to the
next line
now as I resize the viewport instead of
resizing elements it wraps the first
element and then only resizes when it
really needs to so far we've only looked
at two properties of the Flex container
there are several others worth looking
at